головнішим із виступу президента знаєте
на те є класика є наш видатний Микола
гогаль і Мертві душі И виделось ему пруд
и мост через пруд каменный и с двух
сторон его стояли крестияне и продавали
всякие разные товары и лицо его В этот
момент делалось таким сладким правда всё
это так и оставалось в прожектах это про
манилова Мёртвые души і я думаю що тут
краще не скажеш це людина він вже не в
тепліванні він в комусь дуже рячому
басейні в якому він остаточно втратив
зв'язок з реальністю Він розповідає як
все класно в державі що десятки тисяч
гривень зарплати в медиків Він
розповідає як як зараз в нас
обладнується армія І як вона утримується
класно при тому що державна оборона
замовлення виконується тільки на 15% А
всі стратегічні озброєння фактично
перестали закуповуватись він нам
розповідає про те які успіхи на
міжнародній арені при тому що при ньому
були зняті санкції з Росії в паре і ми
бачимо му що відбувається по всьому
світу і як Росія веде свою
пропагандистську діяльність а Україна на
жаль фактично з цим не бореться а він
все зазирає в очі Путіну і багато речей
ще Ну він нам розповів про боротьбу з
корупцією при тому що прямо в сесійній
залі сидить його Депутат який тут брав
десятки тисяч доларів хабарів і він про
це робить вигляд що все є абсолютно
нормальним він сварить правоохоронні
органи кажучи що значить вони робо
працюють незадовільно але всі вони це
його призначенці його друг брат свадба
його стовідсоткова генеральна прокурорка
вже друга і так далі І так далі тобто
він абсолютно знаєте часом складалося
враження що виступає Вибачте Шут але
було Несмішно і навіть не те що не
смішно а навпаки ситуація дуже скрутна і
те що Президент навіть не розуміє тих
викликів які стоять перед державою це
сумно Ну і звичайно що треба дати оцінку
тому що той взагалі-то послання мало
бути в квітні місяці його не було в
квітні місяці тому що розпал
коронавірусу розумієте А тепер
виявляється в нас не розпал хоча в нас
цифри набагато гірші ніж в квітні але
сьогодні він прийшов з посланням чому
Тому що 5ть днів до виборів це був
просто передвиборчий піар і це президент
не України це президент суги народу
заслухали сьогодні ще й профільного
міністра охорони здоров'я ну взагалі ми
знаємо що серед ваших колег народних
депутатів дуже багато нарікань на
міністрів і все ж таки це якась така
спільна відповідальність і президента і
кабіну хто сьогодні несе все ж таки
найбільшу відповідальність за те що
відбувається в державі бо президент
фактично говорив про рік що минув що
проголосували про народних депутатів і
менше про свою роботу і кабіну ви знаєте
взагалі все це нагадувало я ще хочу дати
цьому оцінку Верховну Раду Української
Радянської Соціалістичної республіки осе
це переривання бурхливими оплесками з
боку слуг народу це такі собі гурбангули
Зеленський чи Володимир бірдимухамедов
ось класичне абсолютно і вони один
одного люблять оця вся Вибачте шайка яка
захо хопила 295 квартал і цирк Шапіто
який захопив владу в державі і роблять
вигляд що все гаразд і вони ні в чому ні
за що не відповідальні що стосується
міністра охорони здоров'я тільки що я
йому поставив декілька простих дуже
простих запитань в мене була одна
хвилина я в ці хвилини поставив наступні
запитання Чому більша частина фонду
боротьби з ковід-інфекцією пішла на
Асфальт і як він особисто як міністр за
це голосував він пішов від цієї
відповіді друге питання чому в нас
сьогодні люди щоб протестуватись платять
тисячі гривень власних грошей а потім по
2тч дні чекають на результати це же
абсолютно є неприйнятним він на це
питання не відповів третє запитання Чому
сьогодні в Україні офіційна цифра 120
тестувань на тиждень на 100 000
населення при тому що мінімальна цифра
яка встановлена ЄС норматив 300 тобто В
2 З по разив більше і саме тому сьогодні
українцям закрита Європейський союз вони
нам безвіз перетворили не без виїзд і це
Зеленський сьогодні розповідав нічого не
загрожує безвізу де він твоя робота
призвела до того що ніякого безвізу
фактичного немає тому що люди не можуть
виїхати що нам відповів Міністр охорони
здоров'я фактично нічого четверте
питання Чому через рік ну Вибачте там
через 7 місяців після початку епідемії
тільки 40% ліжок для лікування хворих на
ковід обладнано киснем тільки 40% в чому
проблема це було зробити за с місяців
маючи колосальні мільярди гривень
виділених в ковід-фонд на всі ці
запитання від в віди немає а Міністр
охорони здоров'я це сьогодні ж теж була
ще одна піар-акція Він же перший номер
слуги народу на місцевих виборах тобто
під час такої він розповідав сьогодні
яка страшна епідемія з якою людство
давно не стикалося так під час такої
страшної епідемії ти Міністр охорони
здоров'я замість того щоби боротися за
життя пацієнтів пішов боротися за голоси
виборців а чи не здобувало вас що під
час послання президента найголовнішою
небезпекою ну принаймні яку бачить
Володимир Зеленський Це була опозиція бо
дуже багато він звертався власне до вас
Я так розумію що європейська
Солідарність оце головне завдання яке
ставить президент я не знаю на наступний
рік перед парламентом що що робити з
опозиційною фракцією ви розумієте чому
зараз Бачать тільки вас ну знаєте як
кажуть поганому танцору як і поганому
президенту завжди Щось заважає в даному
випадку зеленському заважають опозиція
вона заважає йому
працювати я навіть не буду це
коментувати тому що ми як відповідальна
державницька політична сила пропонуємо
як боротися з ковід-інфекцією що робити
з економікою яким має бути державний
бюджет наша політична сила починаючи від
лідера Порошенка закінчуючи кожним
народним депутатом за власні кошти купує
медичне обладнання маски засоби захисту
везе це лікарям і займається кожного дня
проблемами людей я вчора цілий день
привів на своєму виборчому окрузі в тому
числі зустрічаючись з лікарями і для
того щоб вирішувати ті проблеми які є і
реагувати на ці безглузді якісь його оці
репліки і посилання на нас ти півтора
роки президент А мені здається що в його
голові президент До сих пір Порошенко Ну
і на останок про Постанову яку сьогодні
голосували чим вона відрізняється від
того що народні депутати вже робили бо
ми пам'ятаємо створювався ковідний фонд
дуже багато було роботи для того аби
держава справді займалася протидією
цьому вірусу А тепер ми бачимо що вже
якесь новий етап в чому відмінність для
того аби українці розуміли Чим сьогодні
ви покращили життя там є декілька
конкретних речей але які тепер мають
втілити в життя і ми дійсно вже приймали
рішення про безкоштовні тестування але
їх немає Ми знов прийняли рішення що
люди мають тестуватися безкоштовно що до
людей має приїжджати машина і забирати
матеріал для тестування а не щоб вони
ходили і розносили Вибачте віруси коли
йдуть чи стоять в чергах а потім через
декілька днів ходять за відповідями Ми
сьогодні прийняли рішення про доплати
також не медичним працівникам швидкої
допомоги бо там є водії і так далі і
всімлі медичним працівникам які працюють
в тих закладах які надають допомогу
хворим на ковід ми ці рішення сьогодні
прийняли Але дійсно багато з них ми
приймали і раніше і вони абсолютно ніяк
не виконувалися на жаль цим урядом але
те що може Верховна Рада вона робить
Вона приймає рішення вона дає чіткий
дороговказ що робити і не можна сказати
що бачите депутати вони не кажуть нічого
не роблять кажуть роблять будь ласка
виконуйте дякую дякую